whether a person can donate something
from his body donate blood in this case
is that allowed during the fast when a
person donates blood it's somewhat like
cupping cupping means removing blood
from the body to the surface either by
sucking or by cupping it is somewhat
similar as far as this is concerned
there is difference opinion amongst the
scholars can you donate blood or is
cupping allowed while fasting or can a
person come there's a Hadith which is
mentioned in Sun Abu da volume number
two in the book of fasting Hadith number
2364 where a beloved Prophet M wasallam
said anyone who cups and gets
CED they break their fast is the person
who
cups and a person who gets
CED breaks the fast but there's also
another Hadith inkari number three in
the book of fasting number 1938
where it's mentioned that Muhammad
sallallahu Ali wasallam was CED while
fasting because of these two Hadith the
difference opinion in the scholars
there's one group of Scholars who say
that because mammad sallallahu Al
wasallam gave a
Commandment that the person who gets CED
and the person who cups he breaks the
fast cupping is prohibited blood
donation is prohibited the other Hadith
is an action the first Hadith is a
commandment so when a commandment and
action ifes the Commandment has got more
value So based on this there is a group
of schol who say that blood donation is
Haram amongst these Scholars we have
Imam Ahmed hbal we have she bin baz who
says that cupping and blood donation is
Haram we have the great scholar Shi who
says it's Haram shik Sal fan and Sh jiin
all of these Scholars says cing is Haram
and Sh jiin says that if a person
donates blood it's like cupping
therefore it's Haram but if he does it
to save somebody's life it is
permissible but yet it breaks the fast
and he has to make up for that fast
later on now there's another group of
Scholars where Alani he says that the
earlier Hadith of Abu da it has been
abrogated by the Hadith of
sari therefore cupping is allowed and
donating blood is allowed so the second
group of Scholars will say blood is
allowed and cing is allowed while
fasting and does not break the fast we
have
Alani we have among the sa Malik may
Allah be pleased with him we have AA may
Allah be pleased with her we have IM
Malik we have Imam Shafi so there's
another group of Scholars who say that
blood donating does not break the fast
so based on this there are some Scholars
who say it's Mak some Scholars say that
if there's such a large difference of
opinion so if it has to be done avoid it
and do
it after Sunset so we have difference
opinion as far as blood donation is
concerned but as far as the other things
are concerned for example if there's a
small bleeding due to any injury that
does not break the fast there's no
difference opinion in this or if you
take blood only for testing a few mL of
blood is remov from the body for testing
that does not break the fast or an
injury and a cut the blood com low
doesn't break the fast
or if it's a nose bleed or bleeding of
nose it doesn't break the fast or if
it's a minor surgery where little blood
flows out it doesn't break the fast if
excessive blood flows out in a blood
surgery which is equivalent to blood
donation then it breaks the fast so as
far as the second part is concerned
about blood taking out for testing nose
bleed or minor bleeding there is no
difference of opinion all of them agree
that this does not break the
fast these are issues which frequently
come up in conversations in the UK and I
believe that we've answered quite a few
of them there today so very very
beneficial indeed